مساء الخير عليكم واسف مره تانيه على
التاخير يمكن في البدايه عايز اشكر يعني
عمرو اللي كلمني واشكر القائمين هنا في
البي اي واي حد فكر ان انا اكون موجود
معاكم النهارده دي فرصه وساعدني جدا جدا
جدا وعايز اشكر الناس اللي قدمتني ميرسي
جدا ليكم انا بس مي 82 مش
92 بقى اضغط بكتير الحقيقه انا انبسطت جدا
جدا من يعني التوبك اللي احنا ممكن نكون
بنتكلم فيه النهارده او
باورنت فكره التمكين وفكره ان كل واحد
فينا ما يصبش بحاله من الاحباط ويكون عنده
هدف ممكن يكون عايز يوصل لله كلام محمد
تهامي قاله كلام جميل جدا جدا جدا جدا
وكلام فعلا يشجع اي واحد فينا استفدت منه
واعتقد كل حضراتكم استفدتوا منه ان كل
واحد فينا يبقى عنده هدف ممكن حتى يكون
بسيط جدا جدا بس يكون بيسعى له فيتحول حلم
البسيط ده ان يبقى اشهر حد في مجاله او
اشهر حد في مكانه الحقيقه كل واحد فينا
ممكن هدفه في حياته يتغير كل فتره يعني كل
فتره يبقى في هدف مرحل انا يمكن دلوقتي في
اجمل فتره في حياتي ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
اكرم عليا بيه يمكن اقدر اتكلم معاكم فيها
بشكل فيه تفاؤل لان ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
بعد اكرمني بعد ما اكرمني بزوجتي من حوالي
سنه ونص كده اكرمني بعد كده ببنتي اس اسيا
هي دلوقتي عندها شه عندها شهرين و2 يوم
بالظبط فكنت دايما بسمع عن ا يعني من
اصحابي من المتجوزين قبل مني ومخالفين
يقولوا لي الجواز حاجه والخلفه حاجه تانيه
خالص يمكن محمد ت شرقني فيبقى عارف الكلام
ده لما تقعد قدام بنتك او ابنك هتحس بشعور
ومشاعر انت ممكن ما تكونش متخيلها في
حياتك فعلا ده انا حسيته لان ممكن اكون
يوم عندي فيه تعب على قد ان سنها صغير بس
يوم يكون عندي فيه تعب او يوم يقابلني
مشاكل في حياتي بشكل عام مجرد ان انا برجع
البيت بلاقيها قدامي حتى لو ناينه او حتى
لما بفكر فيها واحلم ان ممكن تكون علاقتي
بيها ايه لما تكبر وان انا وهي نبقى اصحاب
وان انا احب اعمل لها احسن حاجه في الدنيا
ده بيديني طاقه ايجابيه غير طبيعيه لما
بقعد جنبها واشوفها وهي بتتحرك وهي بتتكلم
طب ما بتتكلمش بس يعني تطلع بعض الاصوات
تحرك اديها تلعب معايا شوف اديها فكر
دايما في قدره ربنا سبحانه وتعالى ازاي ان
الحاجه المسوق الصغير جدا جدا ده في يوم
من الايام هيبقى بني ادم كبير فيزيكي وبني
ادم كبير في مجاله او يقدر يشتغل ويقدر
يعني يبقى طالب علم ويكبر في شغله بشوف قد
ايه ان كل الكلام ده ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
بيسوق لي اسباب صغيره جدا يعني ايه عشان
تكبر فيزكل بناكلها الاكل ده بعد كده تكبر
شويه تاكل رز حااجات كلها بسيطه بس لو
جينا عملنا مقارنه بين الحاجات البسيطه دي
وبين ان البني ادم ده يبقى حد كبير طوله
مثلا 180 سم بالعقل كده مافيش يعني فقد
ايه ربنا بيوجه ل ان احنا ناخد بالاسباب
نعمل الحاجه الصغيره وهي بعد كده ممكن بدي
النا نتائج كبيره جدا جدا اكبر بكتير من
اللي احنا نتوقعه عشان كده يمكن النهارده
في اول حاجه من الحاجات الاربعه اللي عايز
اتكلم معاكم فيها وهي صغئر الامور ان احنا
مش عايزين نستصغر ابدا اي شيء سواء ايجابي
او سلبي ممكن تبقى حاجه سلبيه صغيره جدا
جدا جدا احنا بنعملها مش واخدين بالنا او
بنست الضرر بتاعها بس يبقى سببها ان احنا
بعد كده حياتنا كلها تتضر بشكل سلبي اكبر
وممكن تبقى بركه حياتنا او بركه شغلنا
بتقل كمثال ان حد ح فينا ممكن يكون في
شغله ما بيهتم بشغله بيكسل في شغله بير مش
مشكله كده شغلي ما بريش ربنا فيمان ساعات
بطق شغلي لحد ان بيذاكر وهكذا حاجات بسيطه
جدا ممكن نكون بن تصغرها بس تفرق جدا جدا
في حياتك وكذلك الحجات الحاجات الايجابيه
كتير مننا ممكن يكون مثلا بيصلي حاجات
وحشه بيدي صدقات بسب حاجات تانيه برض او
حشوف خلاص بقى بعمل الحاجات الوحشه مش
مشكله الحاجات الصغيره قوي اللي انا
بعملها بالعكس الحاجات الصغيره دي ممكن
يكون ربنا سبحانه وتعالى جعل هي دي الباب
اللي بينك وما بينه ولما تفضل هي موجوده
هي اللي بعد كده هتخليك تبطل الحاجات
الوحشه مش العكس ماخليش باب الشيطاني يدخل
لنا فكره ان احنا لما مش اعمل كويس ير ما
ابطل وحش لا انت افضل اعمل كويس حتى على
صغره وطبعا حب الا الاعمال الى الله اقلها
ادوام واقل حتى لو هي صغيره افضل ها هي
اللي هتودي الحاجات الوحشه هي اللي هتخليك
بعد كده تبطل الحاجات الوحشه كلها هنا
يظهر النقطه الثانيه بعد فكره صغائر
الامور سواء ايجابيه او سلبيه يظهر النقطه
الثانيه عايز اتكلم معاكم فيها وهي
الاراده مهم قوي ان اي حد فينا يبقى عنده
اراده قويه انه يقدر يعمل حاجه يعني انا
عايز اعمل الحاجه دي كتير من انا يقعد
يقول انا عندي طبع مثلا عصبي او ان انا
مثلا ما بحبش اصحب ادري او كل الطباعه دي
دي كلها ا حاجات بتوجد في الانسان بس يقدر
يغيرها لو عنده اراده لو انا عندي اراده
ان انا مثلا سي اروح الجن واعمل جسم جامد
جدا جدا هستحمل ان انا اروح الجن بشكل
يومي هستحمل ان انا يكون اكلي كله واكل
هيلفي هستحمل ان انا في الوقت اللي اصحابي
ممكن يكونوا بيخرجوا فيه لا انا برجع بدري
شويه عشان انام عشان جسمي يستفيد بساعات
النوم بالليل وقيس على ده تجارب كتيره
وحاجات تانيه كتير كل واحد فينا لما بيحب
حاجه ويبقى عنده الاراده انه ينجح فيها
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى بيسخر له كل شيء عشان
ينجح في الحكايه دي في حديث يعني يمكن
ضعيف بس ناخد منه المعنى كويس عن سيدنا
محمد عليه الصلاه والسلام ق انما العلم
بالتعلم وانما الحلم بالتحلم يعني الواحد
لو عايز يتعلم حاجه حتى لو عمره معرفه قبل
كده يقدر يتعلمها ولو حد عصبي جدا وعايز
يبقى حليم وعايز يقدر يقرن غيثه وغضبه
يقدر يبقى كده لو برض لو وطبعا كتب استاذ
محمد التهاني وغيره كتير من اللايف الناس
المحترمه اللي بتقدر تورينا ازاي اساليب
نقدر نستخدمها عشان نوصل لحاجه زي دي ففكه
الاراده مهمه قوي بس الاراده عشان نقدر
تكون موجوده عندنا طول الوقت احنا فق في
الاخر بني ادمين فاكيد في وقت ارادتنا
قويه امتنا عاليه في وقت تاني ممكن نبقى
اضعف عشان ردتنا طول الوقت نحاول ان ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى يجع القويه ده ياخدنا
للنقطه الثالثه وهي الصحبه مهمه قوي ان اي
حد فينا يكون في انيرت ايجابي الفنت
الايجابي مش بتكلم عليه من ناس صحابي
ياخدوني بس ان انا اروح معاهم درس دين او
جامع او الفنت الايجابي مش متعلق فقط بمود
الدين متعلق بامور الدنيا يعني يبقى معايا
صاحب يي على الخير الخير لنفسي والخير
لبيتي والخير لاهلي والخير للي حواليا لو
لقي ان انا بص وان عندي تاني برزنتيشن
مهمه لا يقوللي انا روح دلوقتي عشان شغلك
ما يجيش يقوللي على حاجه هو عارف ان انا
بحبها وبضعف قدامها لو قاللي تعال نعمل اي
حاجه هروح معاه ما يجيش يقولي ده بجد اللي
بيحبني فكل ما كانان الواحد موجود في صحبه
كويسه موجود في بيئه ايجابيه دي بتسعد
كتير جدا ان قارته تفضل طول الوقت عاليه
وان همته تفضل طول الوقت عاليه مهم قوي ان
احنا نوجد لنفسنا البيئه اللي متفقه مع
اهدافنا يعني انا واحد عايز اوصل لاخر
المكان اللي انا موجود فيه ده يبقى حواليا
الناس اللي تساعدني على ده وطول ما انا
اكلت نيتي صادقه مع ربنا سبحانه وتعالى في
الوصول اي هدف ربنا سبحانه وتعالى على قد
ما انا بسيب ابي كع صحابي ال المترك شاعر
الله عوضه الله خيرا منه طول ما انا بسيب
حاجه عشان ربنا يعيني الوصول لهدف
محترم وهدف حلال ربنا هيعي وهوج لي حواليا
الصحاب الكوييسين هيوج لي حواليا ان شغل
كويسه حتى لو في الاول بنك شويه عاب ب
شويه عربيه لان اي حاجه كويسه اي حد فينا
بيعملها لازم هيلاقي الاول حاجه صعبه بتعو
يعني انا شايف واحد من السبيكر الجمال
اللي هيتكلموا النهارده استاذ تمم البشير
من اجمل الناس اللي انا بحب فيهم اعمال
المشر بروجرام حلوين جدا واحد على طرا
المحور واحد على ازاعه الفم قد ايه حد اخر
حاجه ومساحه في الاعلام محدش خالص بيتكلم
عليها محدش خالص بيروح لها بس هو بيحبها
وعنده كشر في الحاجه دي صبر عليها اكيد
قدته صعوبات كتيره جدا في الاول عشان حد
يقتنع بفكر البرنامج بيتكلم عن العربيات
في مصر وعشان حد يتكلم يساع ان يعمل
بروجرام يكون بيتكلم على تكنك في حته
العربيات بس اكيد ربنا سبحانه وتعالى لما
له صدق ولا ان هو حطط نفسه في الجو اللي
يخليه يوصل لده ساع غ ما بقى ناجح وبقى
ممكن يكون ليدر في الحته دي دلوقتي بعد ما
اتكلمنا على فكره صداه الامور نهتم بيها
سواء سلبيه او ايجابيه نمره اتنين بنتكلم
ان كل واحد فينا يبقى عنده اراده قويه في
الوصول لهدفه نمره لاثه ان احنا نحط نفسنا
احنا اللي نحط نفسنا ماستناش ان الظروف
تتهيا لينا ان احنا
نوجد في بيئه ايجابيه لا احنا اللي نزرع
نفسنا اللي عايز يعلم حاجه وعايز ياخد
حاجه يروح لها نزرع نفسنا في وسط ناس
كويسين ونزرع في نفسنا في وسط مجموعه
تساعدنا نوصل لهدفنا يمكن الحاجه الاخيره
والمهمه او قبل الاخيره والمهمه اللي
عايزين نكون متكلمين فيها مع بعض هي
الحكمه بتاعه ربنا سبحانه وتعالى حكمه
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى كتير جدا من انا ممكن
حد يكون عايز حاجه كويسه يعني عايز حاجه
بشكل كبير ومقتنع بيها
وسعى اليها بس في البدايه يحس ان ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى مش موفقه او يحس ان في عرقل
كتير بتبع عن الموضوع ده ده طبيعي جدا لان
ماحدش فينا يقدر يستوى حكمه ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى بالكامل يعني صديقي الجميل واخونا
مصطفى حسني ليه مثل انا بحبه جدا في جزئيه
الحكمه وهي ان انت ممكن لو جيت قلت لواحد
فيكم من حضراتكم خد الكوبايه دي وحطلي
فيها ما نهر النيل هيجيب بمقدار الكوبايه
دي او بمقدار الاناء او الوعاء اللي هو
ماسكه لكن استحاله مهما كان في وعاء هيكفي
يه نهر النيل كلها كذلك حكمه ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى ممكن الحكمه في موقف معين احنا
نقدر نستوعبها نقدر نقول ليه ربنا بعد عني
دي عشان في حاجه تانيه احسن بس ده
مابيحصلش في كل الاحوال ا كتير ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى بيوجه ك في حته وانت تكون
اصلا رايح في حته تانيه خالص تبقى زعلان
جدا انا ليه ما رحتش في المكان ده انا ليه
ماكسبتش الشغلانه دي ليه ماخدتش الفلوس دي
بس ربنا ريت خير اكتر يمكن في قصه يعني هي
تو ستوري حصلت بره وبحبها جدا ان ساعات
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى يكون شايف حد فينا
حاجه هو مش شايفها في نفسه وبثق له الناس
اللي يقري ربنا سبحانه وتعالى على لسانهم
الحاجه دي فالبني ادم يعرف الحاجه في نفسه
اللي ماكش عارفها قبل كده القصه دي بتقول
ان كان في زنس مان واقف في محط فلقى مشحات
بيبيع زي الناس اللي كان ممكن تكون يعني
بتشوفهم ماسكين مناديل او حد بياخد منك
فلوس وما بيديك المناديل او انت ما بتاخدش
منه المناديل يعني عطفه منك عليه فالبز
مان ده بعد مد الراجل بيبيع ل الصاص يه
فلوس وركب عربيه المترو راح راجع تاني
راجع تاني وقال له ايه بقى قاله انت زنس
مان شاطر جدا والليس قوي راح واخد ق رصاص
وقابل الفلوس اللي هو اديه له هو كان
بيشجعه انه يشتغل مش بس يتكسب او يعني
يبقى مكسبه من عط الناس عليه بعد فتره
طويله البزنس مان ده واقف في حفله او في
جاذين يعني لقى شخص داخل انيق ومهن وجميل
داخل عل انت ما تعرفنيش ولا تعرف اسمي ولا
انا اعرفك ولا اعرف اسمك بس انا عمري ما
هنساك طول ما انا عايش لان انت اول واحد
افدت نظري ان انا ممكن ابقى زنس مان شاطر
وان انا ممكن ابقى تاجر شاطر و اللي
شجعتني بالكلام اللي انت قلته لي لان غيرك
كتير كان بيديني فلوس ويمشي من غير ما
يقول لي اي حاجه او يعني اللي هو بيشجعني
بس كده بيعف عل لكن ما بيشجعني ان انا
اتكسف واشتغل بجد عشان اقدر اجيب فلوس لله
المثل الاعلى ده بني ادم شاف بني ادم حاجه
هو مش شايفها في نفسه وشجعه عليه بكم ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى ك بنبقى احنا ماشيين في
طريق وشيفين ان احنا انجح حاجه لنا الطريق
ده بس ربنا ياخدنا بطريق تاني خالص هو
قدرى الناس ان ده يبقى احسن حاجه لينا اخر
حاجه مرتبطه بجزئيه الحكمه وهي اليقين ان
احنا دايما يبقى عندنا يقين ان احنا يقلنا
بالمسبب سبحانه وتعالى المسبب هو ربنا هو
اللي كل شيء بيتم بقراته وبقوته وجبروته
هو بيس لنا الاسباب يعني احنا بناخد بال
الاسباب عشان نوصل لهدف معين لو عملت
الاسباب اللي عليا وديت ربنا في شغلي عملت
اللي اقدر عليه النتيجه بقى مش بتاعتي
النتيجه دي لازم يكون عندي يقين ان دي
بتاعه ربنا سبحانه وتعالى في من انا ممكن
يبقى مذكر في مبده كويس جدا جدا جدا ويخش
في الامتحان لاقي النتيجه مش زي ما هو كان
مذاكر او مش زي ما كان حالل في الامتحان
والعكس ماده تانيه ممكن يبقى هو مذاكر
بسيط مش حلل الامتحان كويس لا دراجته
عاليه مش معنى الكلام ماذاكرش بس قصدي ان
احنا بناخد بالاسباب نعمل اللي علينا في
شغلنا في دراستنا في كل علاقات حياتنا
النتيجه بتاعه ربنا عمر ما خلي قلبي وانا
بقول الكلام ده بنفسي قبلكم بخلي قلبي
يتعلق ان انا لو عملت ده يبقى لازم ال او
النتيجه الناحيه التانيه تبقى ايجابيه لا
ممكن يكون ربنا جاعل النتيجه تبقى سلبيه
دلوقتي عشان اتعلم منها ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى يحطني في الاختبار الاصعب الاهم
يلاقيني جاهز فبالتالي الورد هنا يبقى
احسن بكتير وحضر لكم مثالين بساط من
تجربتي يعني الاعلاميه الصغنونه جدا جدا
جدا التجربه اللي كان او المشهد اللي كان
اخويا الكريم بيتكلم عنهه بتاع صباح الخير
يا مصر انا في اليوم ده ما كنتش طالع خالص
الاستوديو لان كان في اهالي اللي هم ضحايا
مسبحه بورسعيد ربنا يرحمهم يا رب كانوا
واقفين تحت مسك وماكنتش عارف اط فخلاص
يعني كنت واخد عربيتي
وماشي متاثر جدا بالناس اللي قاعده تتكلم
معايا ل انا انا بطبيعه الحال رياضي وبحب
اروح داما في الاستاد فكنت قل متخيل لو
الموقف ده حصلي مكن وديتي اهلي يبقى ايه
وضعهم يعني في موقف اثرت جدا بيه بس خلاص
واقفين انا عشان الناز دي مافتحش الباب
وما كنتش عارف اخش بالصدفه البحته او مقدر
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى حد شافني من الناس
اللي شغلين زميلنا في التلفزيون وقال لي
تعال هدخلك الباب ورا وكان يعني بالحسابات
المنطقيه صعب جدا يشوف من الدور الخام
فلوس ناس كتير بس ده كان خدر انا والمهم
دخلت وزي ما هو وصل بالضبط ما كنتش محضر
اي حاجه ودخلت وكل اللي في قلبي طلع بدون
اي تحضير بدون اي حاجه مش معنى كده ان انا
لو مش محضر ه كويس ده معناه ان انت كنت من
جوه صادق وبتتكلم ب فعلا باللي جواك
بتتكلم باللي في قلبك ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
جعل يعني مدى كلامك ده او تاثير كلامك
يروح لابعد ب كتير من ما انت كنت متخيل
فانت هنا اخدت بالاسباب اتكلمت باللي انت
تقدر عليه بالي انت شايفه وجه نظرك مظبوطه
وبعد كده انت عليك الاذان و على الله اللي
انت تتكلم الشغل بتاعك دي بتاع ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى والعكس مره تاني او ثالث
مره عنبار ب ما تعين التلفزيون وانا يعني
كان بالنسبه لي جديد ان انا اكلم لغه
عربيه و ستف جدا ناش اخبار ليها طقوس
معينه وك جنبي واحد صاحب صديق ل اسمه ياسر
وكان يعني بيضحك معايا يفكني وعشان ما
تبقاش متوتر و فواضح ان هو فقني بزياده
خالص فانا طالع على الهواء بعد ما كنت
مركز وراجع نشر كذا مره والدنيا تمام جدا
طالع بضحك لدرجه ان انا وشي محمله من كتر
الضحك وقدر ربنا ب الاكتر ان اول خبر معيا
فاكره جي دلوقتي ده كان الكلام ده كان في
2008 كان الاسبوع ال 19 من الدوري المصري
الممتاز ولقاء ما بين الاوليمبي وبتروجيت
وفي الدقيقه ال احرز الاوليمبي هدف الاول
بقدم اللاعب حسن سوسته طبعا احنا في وقت
الهواء تم ب تر في الاستوديو فتقطعه
الكلام بتاعتي جت حسن سوسته اكني قاعد
البار فكل الناس اللي قاعدين في الهواء في
في الاستوديو ضحك طبعا واعين على الارض
وانا على اله روح صوتي مفتوح فانا روح على
الهواء ومش ادر امسك نفسي عمال اضحك اضحك
ومخرج يقول لي لا امسك نفسك امسك نفسك
ومين الاحر زعده هدف التعادل بقى محمد
الفكهاني طبعا انا قلت الفكهاني يه وراحت
مقلوب على الديسك لدرجه ان صوت ضحكي طلع
فالمخرج راح قفل المايك عل وراح مشغل
الفيديو عشان يغطي الصوره عشان انا مش
هينفع عمال يقول لي يا ابراهيم خلاص
الفيديو هيخلص ومعيش حاجه اغطي بيها تاني
تخش الخامره بعديه المهم ساعتها احنا
طلعنا من
الهواء الانطباع اللي واحد ممكن يحضر من
حاجه زي دي دي حاجه شها وحش ومنظري يبقى
واحش ف لما الواحد فكر بعد كده بالعكس ده
كان انسب حاجه في الوقت ده لان كنت لسه
تاني مره او ثالث مره اعمل اشد اخبار فكره
التلقائيه اللي ربنا سبحانه وتعالى جعلني
اطلع بيها دي ان انا بضحك عي وببقى طبعتي
اكتشفت بعد كده من اساتذه لينا في في الاع
ان احسن حاجه ان انت تكون طبيعي تكون بني
ادم ما تبقاش ستف ما تبقاش بتاكد ان انت
روبوت ماغلطش بالعكس انت بني ادم فكره
الغلط هنا اتعلم منها بس ما تخلينيش اقول
ليه بقى حصل كده ده ربنا جعل ده عشان يكسر
الحاجز النفسي اللي ما بيني ساعتها وما
بين الكاميرا راجع معكم بسرعه الفور بوينت
اللي احنا اتكلمنا فيهم نمبر صغائر الامور
سواء سلبيه او ايجابيه نمبر ت ان احنا
نبقى عندنا اراده قويه في الوصول لهدفنا
تالت حاجه ان احنا يبقى عندنا صحبه وبيئه
جميله وايجابيه بتحيط بنا عشان سعدنا على
وصول هدافنا رابع حاجه هي من شطين فكره ان
احنا دايما نبقى بظن في الله حسن ان حكمه
ربنا لينا هي احسن حاجه وترتيب ربنا لينا
هو احسن حاجه وعندنا دايما يقين في الله
سبحانه وتعالى مش الاسباب اللي احنا
بنعملها عشان نوصل لاهدافنا وربنا يكرمكم
يا رب وشكم مره تي موجود معاكم
النهارده